here with reaction Fox News contributor
Charlie hurt an outkick founder clay
Travis
gentlemen thank you very much for
joining me Charlie let's start with you
you see this endless loop of all the
Biden they call them gaffs I call them
lies
that plus I think a pretty rough week
for Joe Biden he's losing to Trump in
the polls he's down by seven in the
swing States he's got some big scotus
decisions piling up against him
obviously a lot of family drama going on
cocaine at the White House what's your
read
yeah but you know all along uh he has
had the Press on his side and I I won't
hold my breath uh that that's going to
change anytime soon uh although I do
think that that story this weekend by
the New York Times talking about the
fact that he is a deadbeat Granddad and
his son is a deadbeat dad who won't even
acknowledge uh I can't even fathom it
quite frankly can you imagine having a
grandchild that you don't even want to
meet that you don't want to see you
don't want to pick up you don't want to
know it's uh you know aside from the the
moral uh appalling nature of all of this
um but uh like I said I I'm not going to
hold my breath uh as long as as Joe
Biden has the press behind him and the
Press working for him working to cover
for him and working to attack his
enemies he's going to be able to to
stand and fight
clay there's no question that Charlie's
right about that the Press protecting
Biden but it sounds like even the
Democratic voters are starting to pull
away from Joe Biden up to a third of the
primary voters are supporting RFK Jr
Marion Williamson none of the above so I
think his presidency is starting to fray
but when you think about the
granddaughter in Arkansas particularly
and it is his granddaughter no matter
what Spin and La he puts on it what are
they communicating to the public these
swing voters who said I want somebody
who's going to unify and get rid of the
drama be a family values president and
here we are
kellyanne you worked for president Trump
can you imagine if he had had a
four-year-old granddaughter that he
refused to acknowledge and even didn't
count I mean that that's cruel in a
level that I don't know we have seen in
a modern era to refuse to acknowledge
that you have a granddaughter to say you
have six grandchildren instead of seven
can you imagine if one of the Trump Sons
had been illegally profiting off of
foreign relationships making tens of
millions of dollars not paying tax on it
had been a drug addict there had been
cocaine found in the White House and the
White House I saw this analogy kellyanne
is running around that's like McDonald's
recognizing that they get hamburger
stolen and everybody's saying oh it
couldn't be the Hamburglar I think the
cocaine probably belongs to the
crackhead son of the president because
it would require such an unbelievable
level of entitlement as you well know to
take cocaine into the White House you
have to be the kind of person who could
drive 172 miles an hour in your Porsche
while on crack and have no consequences
for that behavior or your failure to pay
millions of dollars in taxes or your
failure to acknowledge one of your
children this is unacceptable and I
think kellyanne what It ultimately
brings home is the Cardinal lie of the
Biden campaign was I'll restore normalcy
and honesty and truth and decency to the
White House does anyone Democrat
Republican or independent believe that
Joe Biden has delivered on that promise
I think the answer is no and if he's the
nominee and I don't actually think he's
going to be the nominee I think he
stands a great chance to get his ass
kicked by Donald Trump or whomever the
Republican nominee ends up being because
the American public knows Biden can't do
this job he's got dementia he's not up
to it and he continues to live down to
his obligations as the President of the
United States and the polls meet that
out it's so true clay in fact the ABC
News poll showed that Biden is seen as
both physically and mentally impaired to
actually do the job so to that point
Charlie let me just say for the record I
watched president Trump interact with
all 10 of his grandchildren and he's a
very loving grandfather he doesn't say
he's got nine there's all ten but
Charlie I think on the matter the
cocaine I don't know whose cocaine it
was but I know that there are many ways
that we can find out this is the White
House I walk through the West executive
entrance thousands of times over four
years easily and this is it is it's
swept every day the Secret Service is on
top of it so I want people to understand
the random drug tests that we all took
no tolerance there's these Private Tours
go on there they could be children
walking around obtaining that we all
have a right to know this is not the
Biden's house this is the people's house
and that is in that is a very famous
office building and an important one
where the vice president other
people in power in our government come
through every day so Charlie as a
reporter what do you want to hear next
about the origin of that cocaine well I
it would be great to get a straight
answer from uh them that they won't even
say where it was found
um and as you point out I mean
absolutely nothing goes on anywhere in
that building that that they don't know
about they know exactly where that came
from and if there's going if they're
going to carry on this effort to try to
conceal that I think it uh just sort of
underscores that not only does the Biden
Administration have the uh the the press
behind him but apparently they are
utilizing it and we've seen this in
other areas they're not below this uh or
above this the willingness to utilize
the the federal government in order to
protect them and and enrich themselves
but I honestly believe that part of the
administration would rather be talking
about Hunter Biden's Co or whoever
whoever it is uh the this sort of
cocaine rather than talking about the
Biden inflation talking about the Border
talking about Biden's war in you Ukraine
and talking about all these other things
that that are making people feel poorer
uh uh the the lawlessness around the
country that makes people uh fear for
their lives in their homes and going to
the store
um all of these things that that the
body Administration has no answer to so
they would rather talk about cocaine and
his crackhead son
thank you Charlie clay last couple
seconds here you teased the audience so
complete your sentence if Biden's not
the nominee for the Democrats who is
I think it's gonna be Gavin Newsom I
think there's a reason he sat down with
Sean Hannity In This Very hour uh a few
weeks ago I think Gavin Newsom is in the
wings they're terrified to put Kamala
Harris in because she would be even a
worse nominee than Biden I think Biden
would have already announced he wasn't
going to run uh really kellyanne if
Kamala Harris wasn't such an unmitigated
disaster as his number two I think Gavin
newsom's going to be the nominee so make
America California that may be a tough
sell
play Charlie thank you so much excellent
segment thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else